[Music]
have you heard about the Hyperloop I
have this is very exciting great a lot
of people think it's really cool earlier
this week plans were revealed for a new
high-speed travel system called the
Hyperloop that's right it's got
everybody talking it's a large pneumatic
tube that can carry passengers eight
hundred miles per hour so it can take
you from Los Angeles to San Francisco in
30 minutes that's unbelievable sounds
kind of risky to me I'm sorry who said
that look all I'm saying is the
railroads the only way to travel
Tom Cruise had sex on a train and risky
business don't you want to be like Tom
Cruise okay look of course you would
want people to go by the train you
clearly work for Amtrak yeah I'm just
trying to save lives here yeah well sir
I respect your opinion but please
everyone knows trains are just high
speed coffins buses are the only way to
go plus there are none of those annoying
security checks you can travel with any
weapon you like yeah I hardly think
that's a good reason to want to go in
but okay listen if you ask me people
should only travel by cruise ship all
right no one has ever died at sea
we all know that's not true the Titanic
was a hoax okay
look come on guys just just settle down
okay well peace my brothers
why not control your own destiny and
help the planet to on a Segway plus it's
gluten-free yeah look look you're all
just mentioning different ways to travel
I don't think this is very fellas I have
an idea why can't we all just fly around
on giant kites
shut your damn hole Philip damn you
Philip
that's right Philip get out of here
everyone does spin of it but Philip will
show you all
[Music]
[Applause]
and that ladies and gentlemen was our
expert analysis of the Hyperloop now we
have a great
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]